i got some um inside info on rodney
harrison
uh how he got his wife and pulled her
into the trap i mean you know driving
the pickup truck in college rolling the
window down and coming out with a hey
baby i just showed up on the scene i
said what's up baby what's up oh and she
was like i'm coming
but then i hear the second time you see
her you lie to her until her class has
been cancelled well if she would have
showed up on time she would have she
would have known she would have known
chris you're somebody you know i'm very
disappointed in you mike thank you last
night for the wonderful dinner thank you
for all the pft crew that came out
how could you not show up even our
producer matt casey came out with his
lovely pregnant wife and you go and you
make money you're supposed to come
hanging out with damn right money time
right it's so like
it's about relationships man it's not
about the money damn i spend enough time
with both of you okay i need if florio
wanted to make up the difference for
what i was getting paid
if we'd have paid him what he was going
to make at the other place then he would
have came but you know this is going to
help me with my vacation in a few weeks
see that's why i respect your dad so
much because it wasn't always about the
money you're such an ass
[Laughter]
rodney harrison join us here in miami so
rodney uh we were out in san francisco
when we saw the 49ers before that
playoff game against vikings and you
thought they looked too loose right
yeah i looked at chris and i said hey
man i said am i tripping or are these
guys like overconfident and chris was
like yeah they seem really really
confident but the thing that i i took
from them mike is this is a team that
they really support one another yeah
like when i saw
tevin coleman score those touchdowns
raheem moster came and hugged him and
met breeda and it's just it's a team and
you talk about the closeness of that
team the continuity everything together
i just i like the san francisco's to win
this game because i just think they're
they're a better team yeah they got a
little and it's not to say like kansas
city doesn't have something too you know
they seem like they got a good team or
gel together you're right but like to me
us being out there and then a special
feeling it was a special feeling it
really was it's like they're fearless
and they just they love each other and
they have such belief in their coach and
their coach and the belief in them
though i picked the chiefs i picked the
chief so you you went the other way i
went the other way but you were battling
that week right
he was leaning 49ers all week and then i
could hear early in the week the mahomes
magic there's something about patrick
homes
the looseness we saw that vibe that we
saw we're in their home stadium they had
both of those playoff games at home yeah
can that vibe carry outside of that at
that special place where i don't see why
not i don't see why not this is a team
and when you're a team you believe in
one another you believe in your head
coach and that's one of the things they
all said to me hey when i asked hey man
you ready yeah we believe in kyle
shanahan we believe in kyle shanahan
they believe in their head coach they
feel like they can go their style of
football they can go they can run right
play action pass they got a bunch of
different weapons they can get the ball
out quick they can do whatever it takes
to win the football game i think they
win this game yeah i'm with you what is
what what to you okay is the like the
key to the game for you like what's the
one thing you look at and just go oh
this is interesting but i just think the
49ers were will be better or overcome
the one thing that you know everyone's
talking about the pass rush and the
quarterbacks yeah it's it's open field
tackling it's something that a lot of
teams don't do last year i mean this
past season we saw so many bad tackling
teams but yeah i think open field
tackling i think that's the key because
both offenses have just so many just a
plethora of weapons and that's one of
the things i've been saying about the
49ers they have found guys who can
tackle to the ground who will hit you
who will be physical even though they
don't practice it anymore because i
think that's the problem teams don't
practice with physicality but the 49ers
have a bunch of crazy guys like george
kittle who will go out there and rodney
harrison yeah i mean i just have to
be wired to go out there and play hard
and and they know how to tackle without
practicing tackling i interviewed debo
samuel last week and i asked him i said
coming across the middle what do you
think and he says i think about nothing
all i think about is me catching the
ball and me running someone over so he
doesn't have that threat or that fear of
someone hitting him he just feels like
he can come across the middle but back
in my day i would have knocked his
freaking head off you come across the
middle i know like you got to pay the
price right but nowadays hey he he feels
confident i come across the middle i
don't have to worry about anyone taking
me out see i think there's going to be a
premium placed on finding guys in the
draft and finding free agents who you
can plug into a defense that will go
blow up those running plays that the
guys who know how to tackle who aren't
going to miss the tackles who aren't
going to get abused because they haven't
been practicing tackling because they
only have limited padded practices and
limited opportunities so you think
there's going to be more of a premium of
guys who just show reckless abandon with
their body and throw themselves around
which i i mean i've heard you said that
i i do think but you can't play like
that anymore that's the problem you
can't play like 49ers are playing like
that well they're playing controlled but
it's not many differences
like yeah i mean oh it's not the
old-school way right yeah he's talking
about the new school version but yeah
your guy you knocking people's heads off
over the middle those those days are
done i don't like it i don't how do you
envision if kansas city were to pull it
off right like what do you think it
would take is it a jimmy garoppolo
interceptions or is it just homes just
being on fire i think it's andy reid
stepping outside of his comfort zone
right and as opposed to passing the ball
maybe running getting to damien williams
i think this is a guy that can really
help them kind of be that element of
surprise against san francisco's defense
yeah and damien williams was 12-1 to be
super bowl mvp when i saw that i thought
somebody in vegas knows something right
they know something right that maybe the
chiefs are going to run the ball more
and andy reed won't run that's the thing
he won't run so why not run now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports